Gregory of tour.
Here we enter into a further into a stranger world.
As I told you at the outset of the course,
it begins fairly reasonably as if it's another history course with great powers,
states recognizable theories of government and practices of government.
Now we're into what certainly seems like a combination of thugs and miracles and
I hope that you'll see,
if you haven't seen already that far from being contradictory.
Thugs and miracles go together.
Historically,
we've already entered into a somewhat strange realm with pro copious,
copious secret history certainly is a strange story with strange theories of
causality and a strange cast of characters,
but it is narrated in a high classical style in so far as the pieces are a bit
jumbled.
It's because it wasn't completed,
but as a you will have seen,
if you think about per copious,
he is easy to read because he's leading you on.
He has a set several points to make and he makes them with great rhetorical
power.
His secret history is in the classical tradition of the invective.
And in a way,
we are better able to understand this because our own political discourse has
gotten much more crude and extreme in the last 30 years or so.
So political invective historical invective stylistically well composed is not
unfamiliar to us,
but Gregory of tour is in a way,
I've cheated by giving you the assignment from this edition of Alexander Murray
because he rearranges and excerpts things.
The full work is much fatter.
And Marie tries to make the story fairly coherent with headings,
grouping things together,
explaining a little what's going on to say nothing of the Nice maps and
genealogical tables in the back,
but that loses some of the random quality or seemingly random quality that
Gregory has.
He has this funny way of seeming to move from one thing to another without any
kind of transition or for no apparent purpose.
So in one of the,
uh,
little,
um,
uh,
sections of book three that's not in Murray.
He's,
um,
he's telling us now we have an a miracle there.
Lived at the city of long grow Saint Gregory,
that priest of God fame foreign wide for his miracles in virtuous deeds.
While I am talking about this bishop,
I thought you would like me to tell you something of the town of [inaudible]
where he spent his youth.
Well,
wait a minute.
Did I ask about Dijon?
Do I even know where Dijon is?
Weren't we talking about Theodoric and low thought cloth are and their feud?
How have we gotten into,
first of all,
a story of a saint and second,
a little travel log about Dijon.
So that is Greg,
you've got to like this and I think we are better equipped you,
especially because we're not so linear as we used to be.
You know,
magazines used to be,
you know,
just a set of articles and that was it.
And then about 20 years ago they started just breaking up into these
miscellaneous things,
little observations.
And here's what's happening in Wichita falls.
But you know,
I don't live there,
but so what,
you know,
food festival in Colorado Springs and um,
uh,
you know,
what about this train trip in New Zealand?
Well,
I'm not in New Zealand either.
You know what I mean?
This kind of a little offers from all over the place.
Little possibilities,
observations,
wit and wisdom.
This is the experience of modern media.
So I wouldn't say that Gregory has ahead of his time,
but I don't want you to complain to me.
Well,
I mean you can,
but I will not be incredibly sympathetic with Wade.
I don't know where this stops and begins or wait,
are we responsible for theater,
Burt visit versus the uterus?
The answer to that is no.
Okay.
I'm not going to give you a short answer about,
um,
uh,
you know,
which of these dames is best for your cat or,
uh,
you know,
who our name,
at least five of Clovis has grandchildren.
But the rhythm,
the rhythm of this,
uh,
the um,
power of these rulers there thuggery or their violence,
uh,
their internet seen violence,
their respect for miracles,
Gregory's sense of God's intervention is very important to grasp.
And we will talk about the actual historical importance of this people that
Gregory chronicles the Franks,
the chief thing about the Franks from Gregory's point of view is that they are
Catholic Christians.
They never,
unlike almost all other of the invaders of the Roman empire,
they never go through a period of area aneurysm.
Clovis converts from Paganism to regular Guy Roman Christianity and from Clovis
has point of view.
That is what is up Keefe importance now from Gregory's point of view,
Gregory of tour,
the author is writing in the late sixth century.
So around the same time,
a few decades later perhaps then per copious,
Gregory lived from five 39 to 594 in his time.
There was still a distinction between Romans and barbarians and Gregory,
which very conscious of himself as a Roman.
He was from a distinguished Roman senatorial family.
Note that he uses the word senatorial,
a rank of the Roman empire,
even though the Roman Empire from our point of view certainly hasn't existed for
a hundred years or so.
He notes that 18 bishops of tour,
his see,
uh,
of the 18 bishops of tour,
all but five were related to him.
That shows you that being a bishop was a Roman office,
any elite Roman office even in the barbarian period.
And also you'll see that Gregory's behavior shows us that the bishops to some
extent have inherited Roman offices and Roman responsibilities.
They are part of the government and in a sense opposed to the more brutal
aspects of Merovingian Frankish government.
Gregory became bishop of tour in five 73 and so he was bishop for 21 years.
He probably began writing this book,
um,
which is actually just called the book of the histories shortly after his
election.
So he's writing the five seventies to early five,
nine days.
He begins book one,
which we haven't read with the story of creation and takes it to the depth of
Saint Martin,
the great patron of tour.
And then he begins properly speaking with at least the legendary history of the
dynasty of the Frankish kings,
but descendants of a certain mirror avec hence Merovingians the name for this
dynasty.
Greg,
we also wrote a number of saint's lives and murder stories.
He was very attached to a Saint Martin at one point in one of those episodes,
not in Murray.
He says,
if you celebrate the feast of Saint Martin faithfully,
you will gain the protection of the saintly bishop in this world and the next,
and indeed that's very important.
Remember when Clovis,
and this is in Murray on page 17 when Clovis decides he's going to attack the
Visigoths.
Now he says he's attacking them because he can't stand to have a Ariens
occupying goal.
This is on page 16 then Clovis said to his men,
I take it very badly that these areas hold part of God with God's help.
Let's go and conquered them and bring the land under his authority,
and a soldier seizes,
hey,
from a poor peasant,
this is just the way soldiers are.
They need the Hay.
The civilian has the,
hey,
they're on the march.
He grabs it.
But this peasant is on the lands of Saint Martin of uh,
uh,
land,
belonging to tour.
And the king thug,
though he is,
has issued an order saying the troops were not to take anything except fodder in
water.
And in fact sort of,
hey is fodder nevertheless
the king who quicker than it takes to say it had him put to the sword
guy,
you've made a mistake and he's killed.
Okay.
And Clovis says of this incident,
how shall there be hope of victory if we all offend the blessing,
Martin?
So you've got to take seriously,
if you want to call it superstition,
fine.
But the Frankish rulers are at least amenable to influence from the priests,
bishops,
guardians of the saints.
And notice,
because we're going to come back to this a lot,
you're going to see it everywhere in the early Middle Ages Post Roman world,
the saint is not dead.
It's not like Martin is some just kind of presence the way you know.
Um,
uh,
you know,
the happy dead who are indifferent to us.
Martin is an angry st or potentially angry.
In fact,
all saints worth anything in the early Middle Ages are very touchy.
If you sees,
hey,
from land belonging to their church,
they'll strike you dead or they will see to it that you die in battle.
And Gregory is indeed full of incidents in which holy figures,
alive or dead have this kind of ability to mobilize supernatural power.
Okay.
What is his historical model?
I mean if per copious im in the wars models himself after,
through acidities and if in the secret history he models himself after a
tradition of invective.
What is Gregory's model?
Um,
we don't really know his sources.
One reason why he's so important is that for an awful lot of the history of the
mayor of engines,
he's about all we have and all though disorganized quote,
disorganized from our point of view,
he's very detailed.
But he does have a model.
And that model is the Bible,
the Hebrew Bible or the Old Testament.
If you read the Old Testament,
it is as I think I've said before,
full of violence and full of miracles.
Okay.
And they are sort of jumbled up.
The hand of God is very apparent in the Bible and generally speaking,
those who disobey God are punished.
Okay?
The same is true in Gregory,
although the hand of God is a little more mediated by those holy figures,
saints,
Hermits,
bishops that we just discussed.
There is a little bit more of a priestly power.
But then again,
the Bible has figures like Moses who are able to,
uh,
Joshua who is able to stop the sun,
um,
priestly figures indeed.
So from Gregory's point of view,
there is a continuity between biblical history and the history of his times.
He describes in the prologue to book two is not in Murray that his plan is to
describe the holy deeds of the saints and the way in which whole races of people
were butchered.
Okay.
You got a problem with that.
At least.
The second part,
we all know is what history is about.
It's the first that's a little tough.
The holy deeds of the saints,
and particularly as they're not off on the side,
the popular imagination loves what might be called holy deeds of the saints.
If you look at a gossip magazines of the lower sort or you know,
kind of,
uh,
internet folklore,
um,
weird births,
raining frogs,
uh,
space aliens,
all sorts of supernatural events clog them along with,
um,
you know,
stars that is movie or you know,
media stars,
gossip.
Uh,
and a little bit of history,
a little bit of current events.
This is not so dissimilar in that sense.
Gregory is both a historian and a political actor.
He does not have either the luxury or the irrelevance of most historians now who
sit comfortably or in my case,
not very comfortably since I'm in an unrenovated office,
but comfortably enough and uh,
you know,
universities and I'm maybe comment on what's going on.
No,
Gregory is very,
very involved with the mirror vingean rulers and he has to display courage.
He refuses to surrender fugitives who have sought asylum in his cathedral when
they are demanded by royal officials.
He defends his fellow bishop,
probably tech starters who was accused by the king of treason.
You'll be reading about this for next week.
He'll have arguments again in your reading for next week with the king himself.
About the trinity and has to defend himself against the charge of slandering the
king's concubine or really hear the word concubine isn't quite right because
these things are kind of polygamous against one of the kings.
The king's favorite,
Fred [inaudible] and Gregory is,
is tried,
uh,
for defaming her,
he resists taxes.
He seems to have been a small man.
He suffered ill health,
or at least he took an ignoring and an interest in his own health.
He was a great believer in potions made with dust from the relics and tombs of
holy men.
A medicine prescribed as Pocito day pull Verey support cray dust from,
uh,
a potion made from [inaudible] dust,
but it's gotta be at the right kind of people.
Okay.
What is his attitude towards the Franks?
I've said he regards them as thugs and barbarians,
but at the same time he regards them as the people of Israel re born as a race
favored by God.
The Franks claimed,
or at least their spokespersons,
they're learning.
Spokespersons claimed to be descended from refugees have fallen Troy.
Thus like the Romans.
In fact,
we don't really know anything about them until they appear in Roman sources in
the third century.
Uh,
we don't know what held them together.
We're back to this problem of genesis.
Do they speak a common language?
Do they just travel in a pack together?
Do they regard themselves as a people having a common ancestor?
Well,
we don't really know.
Constantine's father at the end of the third century dealt with them and settled
them in what's now the low countries,
Holland and Belgium,
they were federal rati.
Rick you remember means allied armies of the empire.
They served the empire actually fairly loyal in the early fourth century and
maybe came rich doing so
we don't really know if the supposed ancestors of Clovis Moravec Avec himself,
for example,
were real or legendary.
Supposedly MORAVEC is Clovis.
His grandfather,
we don't know if he existed,
but we do know something about his father.
She'll Parak.
Oh,
well it's a chocolates day.
So the guy's name is kill Peric,
We know about him because his grave was dug up in the 17th century.
Uh,
unfortunately all the stuff that was in his grave,
most of it was stolen in 1831,
but drawings had been made before that and may show,
um,
that he owned or was buried with a cloak embroidered with Cicadas,
a crystal globe of gold bracelet,
a Frankish amulet.
Ah,
his,
what we assume it's his horses head was buried with him and it was covered with
precious metal.
He was also buried with a hundred gold coins and 200 silver ones and a signet
ring,
but it shows him with long hair and the ring is inscribed in case we wondered
who this was.
King Chill Parak the long hair is important.
It is a symbol of the power of these rulers in is a kind of dynastic charisma.
And indeed one of the best books about these rulers by the English history and
English historian is called long haired kings.
What does all this stuff,
the stuff that's buried with him,
a lot of it comes from Byzantium.
A lot of this would have been,
uh,
bribes or,
um,
goodwill gestures by the emperor interested in,
uh,
keeping some nominal loyalty on the part of the barbarian tribes,
in the collapse of the western.
Okay.
Clovis succeeded chill Parak his father as the head of this federated tribe of
now a nonexistent empire.
All the remains of the empire is a Roman commander.
Remember we mentioned in,
uh,
the life of,
um,
of Saint Antonio lists of Nora come that uh,
uh,
an emissary was sent from a Roman army to try to get paid and discovered that
the empire no longer existed,
that there was nobody to pay them a Cya,
angry s s y a g r I u s is a little bit like this.
He's a general in northern goal of the Roman Empire.
And now the Roman empire ceases to exist.
He's on his own and he is a rifle for Clovis.
And one of the first targets of his expansion,
uh,
Gregory calls him king of the Romans.
What does that mean?
Rumsey didn't have kings.
Oh,
we don't really know what title he used.
We have no documents from him,
no coins,
probably Byzantium the eastern Roman Empire didn't like him and probably they
supported Clovis.
At any rate,
uh,
he was killed in four 86 and Clovis,
his next target of expansion was the Visigoths those areas that Gregory tells us
about in the passage that I mentioned to you,
uh,
just a little while ago,
what kind of personality does Clovis have?
Have we met his tight before?
Is there any difference?
Anybody
have a sense of him?
How does he strike you?
Just another,
another one of these characters of the early Middle Ages or is there something
unusual?
We're going to miss fame.
He kills off everybody.
Including his family members.
Yeah.
This is unfortunately not unusual.
And,
and why
it doesn't want any family member.
Yeah.
Wouldn't you think he'd be dynastically?
Uh,
um,
conscious,
uh,
Constantia is the emperor in the fourth century did the same thing.
Uh,
only his nephew's Dallas and Julian survived and indeed Julian defeated him.
MMM.
Is He then just a,
uh,
I mean,
is he then just the same kind of a violent character or randomly violin?
Carrie,
is there a plan besides expansion,
at least in Gregory's portrayal?
Sorry.
Christianity forcing.
Yeah.
He is Christian Christianity.
He doesn't force conversion,
but a,
he himself converts and his men with him.
We know his piety even before the conversion because of this incident with the
silver liturgical bowl or you were
right on page 27,
I am page seven and eight and two 27
stories.
The story seems dubious.
Um,
the story being that,
uh,
they plundered this church,
um,
the church up around us,
they are,
uh,
the Bishop,
asks Clovis for this,
a silver bowl to be returned.
Clovis says he's got a consult his men,
because they have a kind of booty split hand muster.
Notice that this shows a certain leader follower relationship rather than
absolute ruler follower relationship.
Clovis says to his men,
something on the order of me,
Hardy's,
uh,
or uh,
my good men you harvest.
Maybe he's a little too pirate,
like,
uh,
so he begins.
So I want that you were to return it to the church in addition to my share of
half.
And one soldier says,
no,
you get half of that.
Just like everything else takes out his acts.
One of the important weapons of the Franks and splits the silver thing in half.
And Clovis doesn't do anything immediately.
You know,
later muster,
he says to the guy,
recognizing him,
you know,
your,
your kit is a mess.
Your Shield,
you call that a shield and he knocked something down and as the guy picks it up,
Clovis takes up his own acts and splits the guy's head saying as he does.
So Gus,
you did to my car or my basin in Swa song.
Yeah.
Do be a story but interesting because it shows both the power of the ruler and
some limitations as well as his type of piety power.
Uh,
actually,
um,
you know,
the,
the president of the United States actually does it.
The power to kill people.
We've seen it in action,
um,
though a distance and under certain very special circumstances,
but basically,
um,
it takes a certain kind of ruler to be able to kill someone outright like that.
It still happens.
But you know,
we're talking about people like Kadafi or deaths,
pots.
So certainly as with um,
killing the guy who stole the Hay from Saint Martins land,
Clovis is,
uh,
following a certain set of leadership tips that basically amounts to winning by
maximum intimidation.
I think it's fair to say,
but he's got to do this in a careful way because his followers are very
important.
They are powerful.
He does depend on them and he's got to give at least the impression of being the
leader of a band and not the kind of ruler of a state that we might be more
familiar with.
Okay.
Leadership is personal,
but there is a kind of tribal sense or tribal sense of democracy.
The other thing about this story of course,
is once again,
the controversy is over piety towards things of the church.
Even before Clovis has,
at least according to Gregory,
officially converted.
Okay.
It's not that you should be nice to the church because it's good to be a nice
person.
It's that you've got to be nice to the church because the church is in command
of supernatural weapons that will overcome the weapons of this world,
the supernatural interpenetrates,
the physical or historical at every point in Gregory's narrative.
So the overwhelming fact for Gregory's I said before is that he is Orthodox or
Catholic,
I.
E not area.
Okay.
Clovis is in Gregory's eyes.
The new Constantine,
someone who has miraculously been turned thuggish though he is,
and Constantine was as well
to,
uh,
advance God's work.
Of course,
Gregory regards him as a barbarian and he shows him as a barbarian.
He portrays him honestly,
or at least unflatteringly as was said,
he murdered his family.
And then moreover,
if you remember on pages 19 and 20,
he pretends to be really sorry that he can't find anybody that he's related to.
He's he always searching,
uh,
find my family.com or,
you know,
genealogy or a high school classmates,
uh,
anybody who could be his friend,
but in fact,
um,
uh,
he is,
um,
just circling them out to Kelvin and he's got all sorts of tricks to kill his
relatives.
Nevertheless,
in the same chapter that describes his trick on,
uh,
Clo Dereck Gregory tells us,
having inquired the kingdom of city to,
and it's treasury,
he also received those people under his dominion for daily.
The Lord laid his enemies low under his hand and increased his kingdom because
he walked before him with an upright heart and did what was pleasing in his
sight.
Right.
This is just after Clovis,
after the death of CG Burt calls all the people together
says,
I don't know what happened.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the sons of [inaudible] seems to have died as they were showing my invoices.
Treasure a here's my proposal,
make me king.
And they say,
oh,
okay,
great.
Yeah.
Um,
step on the shield and a will lift you up just like the Roman emperors.
Yeah.
It's Gregory a comedian
or is he saying,
and I think this is more likely,
although he is hilarious to read.
I mean,
I hope he's amused you.
I hope while you were cursing me for giving you this assignment or at least
praying to some saints to strike me a dumb or uh,
to erupt and boils or,
um,
probably not anything very strong like,
you'll notice that occasionally people,
people lose their intestines when they go to the bathroom.
Uh,
probably not,
uh,
the,
the heretic areas for example.
Um,
and others who betray the saints.
Anyway,
whatever curses you were,
um,
uh,
summoning up to me.
I hope you actually,
uh,
found this a fun,
this of course is fun as I think I told you way back in,
uh,
the beginning of September.
So,
um,
what was the part from the fun angle?
The people are instruments of the Lord and they walk in the sight of the Lord
even if they are not themselves.
Good people.
The Lord makes use of instruments of people who are forceful.
It's important to be forceful.
If Clovis was a nice guy and we'll see and have already seen some examples of
rulers who nice,
often intellectual and ineffectual.
Gregory prefers effectual with some violent touches to ineffective school
because being a ruler is a hard job and a barbarian world in a fallen world,
Gregory in the census like Augusta,
the world is fallen.
The world is corrupt.
There are no good people in power,
and if they are in power,
it is either unusual or they're not going to be in power for long.
Therefore,
it is important to be violent.
It is important to be able to intimidate your troops.
It is important to seek out those who would oppose you and if they've got to be
killed,
they've got to be killed.
The reason for this is that the work of the Lord has to be advanced according to
Gregory and the church has to be protected.
For Gregory is
exemplifying what I said would happen as predicted by Saint Augustine.
The empire might cease,
but the church would not.
The Church would deal with whatever successors came up.
B,
they Arian or preferably not be they cultivated or more likely barbarian,
and as barbarian leaders go,
Clovis and his sons were not so bad.
Okay.
We're not really sure how Clovis converted because Gregory is invested in a
story that likens Clovis to Constantine.
We have the same kind of thing,
uh,
before a battle.
He,
uh,
makes a deal with God that if he wins the battle,
he will convert.
Um,
we don't really know if he was converted before this battle and four 94 as
Gregory reports or maybe in a battle against the Visigoths and five oh six,
but it doesn't really,
uh,
it doesn't really matter.
It's very important that the Ariens be defeated.
He's got a story that's not in,
uh,
Marie,
in a book to chapter 23 in which an Aerion bishop named Crayola,
y,
O l I,
Crayola,
crayola creole law is angry because he sees the Catholic bishops performing
miracles all over the place.
So he pays a guy to pretend to be blind and then to greet him as he comes to
church and beg him to heal his site and then to say,
oh my gosh,
I've been healed.
My,
I can say,
uh,
but God punishes this by,
making him actually blind at this point.
And then the guy very helpfully from the Catholic point of view said,
oh,
I wasn't blind.
This evil bishop crayola bribed me in order to pretend to be blind.
But now God in his saints,
Saint Martin in particular,
have punished me,
uh,
and um,
so that it takes a Catholic bishop to heal him back to site.
So this is Gregory's attitudes towards the areas.
On the other hand,
he does report that this Frank's besieged Sarah Gosa.
This is a on pages 41 42,
the Spanish city of Sarah goes,
so they've gotten that far in their attacks on the Visigoths,
but the Ariens,
we're able to,
uh,
fight them off.
They circled the walls carrying the tunic of Saint Vincent and singing songs
with the women dressed in black.
Their hair covered with their hair hanging loose,
covered in ashes,
lamented
seeing the situation for you to Bert returned.
He gave up the siege.
The Aryans may be heretics,
but they've got the tunic of Saint Vincent.
And the power of that relic is so great that even in the hands of Ms Grants,
it's not to be opposed to St Vincent,
a very important St uh,
um,
and the patron of Sara Khosa.
So the Aryans are fakes,
but they are not completely without spiritual power either.
And this is a kind of universe in which there are natural and supernatural
forces and it's not the one trumps the other exactly,
but that they both have to be taken into account.
So Clovis consolidates a large kingdom in,
uh,
most of what would become France,
Roman gall,
medieval France,
France named after this group.
The Franks,
the Visigoths now were pushed out into Spain and uh,
um,
just that part of France bordering on Spain.
Clovis received the favor of the church because he was Catholic.
His conversion,
let's say around 500 is 90 years before the Visigoths become Catholic.
And this aids him greatly because the church is in possession of learned people,
financial resources and spiritual power.
So we
followed the Franks and we will follow them up through Charlemagne and his
successors because they are successful
and because their own self consciousness is as uh,
the rightful rulers of the former western empire.
A claim that in various generations is more or less of a reality
and that is by no means inevitable,
but is something that they will eventually make good on for the time being.
Clovis considers himself a representative of the Byzantine Empire,
but a representative who very conveniently doesn't have and to do anything,
the Byzantine Emperor sends him the title of Console.
He's very pleased at this,
but it doesn't,
yeah,
it doesn't a bind him really.
Okay.
So much for Clovis.
Establishment of Frankish had Gemini,
the prominence of the Franks in the post Roman west,
the first Catholic people among the,
uh,
barbarian invaders.
Now we turn briefly to his sons.
He divided his kingdom equally and you have a map in the back,
but it shows the division of the realm under Clovis,
his sons Clo,
Thar shoulder bird,
clo dumber,
and Theo Dereck.
Okay.
This practice of division is dangerous.
It is usually a better idea to give it to one son because then you don't divide
the kingdom.
On the other hand,
if you have four sons who are all militarily competent,
uh,
they're gonna fight with each other.
And in fact they fight with each other.
As Gregory describes in book three,
even though they've been given divisions,
the violence of Clovis,
his sons is crude and even ludicrous.
So,
um,
for example,
this awful incident of closed immers sons being protected by Clovis is Queen Clo
Tilda and her sons,
the boys,
uncles cloth are and Theodoric invite the boys to come for a visit.
And Clotilde though who seems rather credulous says great idea once they are in
the power of these two brothers who of course like Clovis want to kill their
relative,
particularly their younger relatives,
they send a sword and a pair of scissors,
right?
Which will it be?
The Messenger asks the queen cut off their hair or kill them,
cutting off their hair will symbolize that they're no longer eligible for
rulership.
And it may lead to them being put away in a monastery or something like that.
But they're taking early retirement there,
12,
14 years old,
but they've had an,
and Khloe Tilda is so angry,
at least according to Gregory that she says she'd rather see them die and then
may killed them.
They killed them in this ludicrous way because,
um,
uh,
one of them,
it gets cold feet and the other is furious and takes up the sword and just kills
them even though they're begging.
And I mean,
it's,
it's a rather gruesome scene.
Meanwhile,
in a scene that we haven't got in Murray's edition,
um,
for you to,
Rick attempts to kill Clo Tarr.
He invites him.
Uh,
but he's got,
and he's got men waiting to ambush him,
but the,
the,
the cloth isn't low enough down.
They're sort of behind a partition,
a cloth partition,
but cloth are,
can see their feet.
And so he kind of turns back,
uh,
and starts to walk out of the hall and then for you to,
Bert says,
no,
I just invited you to give you a gift.
And he gives him a silver,
you know,
goblet or something like that.
So cloth are escapes from this,
but a theater bird is so angry at having been tricked that he then sends a
messenger saying it was a mistake and to give back the goblet.
So I mean these guys,
um,
what can I say yet beneath the barbarian acts is a society that is still being
governed fairly closely.
There is a fairly sophisticated administration still.
There's a gold coin edge,
which takes a lot of resources to maintain.
These rulers are collecting taxes and they are collecting taxes according to
written records.
There's public land,
there's revenue from land belonging to the king.
The kings are reasonably conscientious about the appointment of bishops.
Okay.
What is Gregory's attitude towards these sons of Clovis?
He certainly portrays them as uh,
fratricidal.
Nevertheless,
on page 26,
he tells us that the brothers were endowed with great courage and had
considerable military resources.
Once again,
their power
is directed more for good and then for bad.
And a lot of their power for bad is merely directed at each other.
Okay.
He considers them,
in other words,
appropriate for savage times.
At one point,
uh,
two of the brothers make war against a third,
specifically children,
Burton theater,
rec against clothes.
Our clothes are,
is the guy who was just been depicted by Gregory as the tough one,
the one who killed the two nephews
and yet
not,
oh,
he was also an adulterer and yet faced with his brothers armies,
he prays to God and his mother,
Queen Clo tilled up praise to Saint Martin.
So powerful are these prayers that the two brothers are unsuccessful,
a hailstorm,
pelts,
their troops,
spares cloth are and cloth are,
is victorious.
The brothers do not succeed in dislodging them
here then we have the power of the mayor of Indians and the limitations on that
power.
The limitations are partly military,
partly that have fratricidal intrigue of people getting killed,
but they're also partly supernatural.
And as you read further into the grandsons of Clovis,
people whom Gregory himself has dealings with,
particularly the way word,
uh,
chill Parak,
you'll see rulers that Gregory considers to be evil and rulers who are really
falling away from the example.
But what interests us in our readings for next week is the nature of this
society.
What's holding it together?
If it's rulers are so violent,
why isn't it not?
Why is it not just falling apart into fragments and shattering?
How could this dynasty rule over a polity for,
um,
something on the order of 250 years?
Oh,
have fun with the papers.
Have Fun with Gregory and we'll talk next week.
Thanks.